[Music]
the year was 1994 and all seemed well at
site 19 researchers administrative staff
containment specialists and guards saw
to their daily tasks as the largest scp
foundation containment site on the books
there was something paradoxically
prestigious and pedestrian about working
at the legendary facility of course
among staff at the scp foundation the
site was famous and took on a certain
mythology around break room discussions
for those who weren't assigned there did
you see the crazy new tech they got at
site 19 it's like something out of star
wars i heard some of the anomalies they
store at site 19 can cause xk class end
of the world scenarios so they've got
hammer down on speed dial you know my
buddy told me that site 19 has a pool on
the fifth floor everyone who works there
gets to go up and chill there once a
week and they've got a dedicated bar up
there that serves cocktails with little
umbrellas all night long of course some
rumors are truer than others not the
pool thing though sorry that one's
complete baloney it is however
completely true of the scp-explained
office but hey that's a story for
another day site 19 as a result of its
size does indeed need a simultaneously
large and elite staff to handle its many
unique containment requirements people
work around the clock to ensure
everything runs smoothly knowing that
the risk of dropping the ball means
death and destruction on a wide scale
personnel have been trained to
meticulously study new anomalies
discover their strengths and weaknesses
drum up ideal containment requirements
and get the situation on mock as quickly
as possible most of the time the
operations at site 19 run smoother than
george benson most of the time of course
with the exception of a few researchers
there sorry dr bright and dr crowe
everyone who works at site 19 is only
human mistakes can happen even when the
cost of those mistakes is much costlier
than when you forget to carry the little
zero on your dull office jobs latest
mind numbing spreadsheet little
oversights can pile up into catastrophes
over time especially when you put your
mind to committing the greatest sin of
all underestimating your opponent
exactly as the scp foundation did one
fateful day in 1994.
you see the scp foundation contains
hundreds if not thousands of new
anomalies every single year when this
job becomes your daily bread and butter
what once seemed exceptionally slow
becomes humdrum and mundane just like
the earlier rumors suggested there are
monsters entities and objects locked up
at site 19 that could cause an xk class
end of the world scenario if they ever
got out could the fine folks staffing
that site really be blamed for not
paying that much attention to some
anomalous sculpture they just weren't
aware how incredibly dire the
consequences of taking your eyes off of
scp-173 were yet but believe me when i
say
they were about to receive a hell of an
education the sculpture had come into
their care a year earlier in 1993 though
the exact circumstances of how it came
to site 19 tend to differ depending on
who you ask its anomalous ability had
become apparent rather quickly at the
expense of a few careless personnel's
lives but hey isn't that always the way
these things unfold the sculpture could
be frozen in place by looking at it
though whenever people turn their gaze
away it moved towards its prey at
shocking speeds and killed them by
either strangulation or more commonly
snapping necks sure it wasn't the kind
of entity you'd want to have a cup of
coffee with or place in your living room
as a striking new object dot but the
foundation had plenty of these so-called
murder monsters in containment already
and this was one you didn't even need to
shoot just looking at it is enough to
freeze it in place a few d-classes were
lost during the first few months of
figuring out the best way to clean the
nasty creature's sell on account of the
fact that it poops constantly but other
than that it was all pretty smooth
sailing they had no idea just how
dangerous this work of malicious modern
art was
this brings us back to that fateful day
in 1994 the day when
scp-173 first breach containment
researcher theo trask was walking down
the large winding halls of site 19
marking off each successfully contained
anomaly on his clipboard it was a
monotonous job but somebody had to do it
he looked through the viewing windows of
all the anomalies that wasn't deadly to
look at taking inventory he worked at
the scp foundation for eight years now
and nothing amazed him anymore he was
thinking about what he might have for
dinner that night or whether he should
go to the movie theater to see that new
film pulp fiction up in the security
office for sector c of site 19. security
officer todd buffett and his men
observed the monitors glowing before
them it was a blissfully boring day one
of them was discreetly playing snake on
his nokia under the table days like this
were made for wasting and they were
tragically few at the scp foundation
where being excited was often the
prelude for being dead todd yawned and
was happy for the privilege to do so in
a darkened sector c server room a group
of engineers performed routine
maintenance they could see their breath
these rooms were kept extra cold to
prevent the technology from overheating
it was intricate work but they were well
trained to do it so much so that they
sometimes slipped into a state of
autopilot while conducting these checks
saving the burden of conscious thought
for meteor tasks further down the line
these were unremarkable tasks on an
unremarkable day and they would be happy
for it all to end and of course it would
just not in the sense that they meant a
mixed group of researchers and
administrative staff sat in the break
room enjoying their mediocre packed
lunch and sharing their own version of
inane office banter it was a nice step
away from the often deadly grind and
shoot the breeze with others in their
line of work after all it was a strange
job with its own unique pressures you
needed to discuss it with others who got
it sometimes just to avoid going insane
from the pressure but then you needed to
avoid the unforgivable blade of this
double-edged sword's mirror half you
never wanted to get too attached to a
co-worker at the scp foundation because
who knows you might not be seeing them
again tomorrow or they might not be
seeing you
back in the surfer bank a junior
technician named colin muntz was about
to make one teeny tiny little mistake
while running diagnostics on one of the
room's power cores he tripped a fuse and
set a terrible chain reaction in motion
cables running all through site 19
caught the shock waves of colin's poor
decision in a moment causing a series of
power cuts that ran through different
systems throughout the facility each one
tripping the next like proverbial series
of tumbling dominoes back to researcher
theo trask lazily ticking boxes on his
clipboard he was about to do another one
and break for lunch when the lights
overhead suddenly went out leaving him
in a dark hallway he was immediately
broken from his trance heart beating 20
to the dozen seconds passed and the dark
somehow remained what was going on here
it didn't make sense surely the
auxiliary generator should have kicked
in by now right and on any other day it
would have but unluckily for theo trask
this just so happened to be the one day
in the last several months that the
facility's main backup generator was
also experiencing routine maintenance
sometimes life just isn't fair trask
felt his heart leap up into his throat
as a door somewhere behind him slowly
creaked open with a torturously long
metallic screech trask didn't have a gun
or even a taser but he did have a small
flashlight attached to his belt with a
draw speed that would rival clint
eastwood in this prime the terrified
trask whipped out his flashlight and
shone it in the direction of the noise
his beam caught a static figure staring
at him without a face the rigid soulless
body of the sculpture
scp-173 was standing less than 10 feet
away from him in this light its smears
of krylon based spray paint looked
almost like a mocking grin your move
researcher it seemed to say trask had
broken into a cold sweat his hand was
shaking but he needed to keep the beam
on that monster whatever tripped the
power must have compromised the system
that governed the sculpture's electrical
deadbolt and unless the light bulbs came
back on and the hallway was suddenly
flooded with other personnel and a
forklift to get that miserable chunk of
concrete back into its cell then he was
in real trouble he couldn't run it would
kill him the second he turned around and
he couldn't walk backwards one trip in
the dark and he'd be found dead on the
ground head facing in the wrong
direction all he could do now was home
hope and of course not blink but as the
seconds passed and the pressure mounted
this became harder and harder to achieve
he could feel the surface of his eyes
drying out leading to a sharp stinging
sensation still the sculpture lingered
and waited as researcher trask's eyes
began to water people should be coming
shouldn't they surely help would be on
the way but he couldn't hear footsteps
or the squeaking tires of a forklift
just yet he couldn't hear anything
except his heartbeat and the blood
rushing in his ears his eyes were
killing him just metaphorically for now
but not for long what harm would one
little blink do only for a fraction of a
second now before we proceed to the
researcher's gruesome and terrifying
death we'd like to perform a quick
experiment with you the viewer of scp
explained we've created a number of
videos exploring the fascinating and
frightening enigma of
scp-173 and one statement seems to pop
up in the comments again and again from
backseat containment experts
why not just blink your eyes one at a
time that's a surefire way to keep it
locked into place okay then let's give
it a try open both your eyes nice and
wide now
blink your left eye and now blink your
right left right left right keep going
while i'm talking don't stop keep it up
how are your eyes feeling it makes your
vision a little blurry doesn't it kind
of makes your eyes sting a little as
time goes on oh look who it is well if
it isn't scp-173
what a surprise and it looks very
interested in you doesn't it
better keep one of your eyes open at all
times left blink right blink left blink
right blink no pressure of course but if
you've closed your eyes at any time
during this little experiment you're
already laying dead on the ground with a
broken neck left right left right do you
feel the burn yet there's no shame in
giving up all it'll cost you is your
life and that's why we don't blink one
eye at a time now
back to the story researcher trask
couldn't take it any longer his aching
eyes fluttered clothes for an almost
imperceptible moment of time and that
was all this sinister sculpture needed
trask felt the impossibly cold concrete
grip of its stubby arms on either side
of his head and a sharp jerk that
communicated the mere moment of
unimaginable pain followed by the
physical answer to silence the sculpture
darted through the darkness of the
hallway with no living eyes left to
freeze it in place in the darkness it
was impossible to defeat it would do the
two things it knew how to do hunt and
murder in the sector c security office
all hell was breaking loose thanks to
con muns's little oopsy in the server
room all the monitors were dark and all
the corded phones that had given them a
direct line to assistants were all dead
they had no idea what was happening out
there maybe they'd all gotten extremely
unlucky and all of the cells were open
whatever caused this catastrophic power
failure must have also knocked out the
alarm system because they were getting
nothing when the door behind security
officer todd buffett and his men opened
he was profoundly relieved to think that
assistance had already arrived he and
his men were a lot less relieved when
they began to fall to the ground their
necks snapped with exquisite efficiency
if you're into that kind of thing that's
because the sculpture had found its way
into the security office and gave itself
more crunch than you'd get from a
family-sized bag of doritos but with
these new victims now little more than
dead meat it was time to move on over in
the break room the collection of
research and administration staff who
were enjoying pleasant chit-chat not
long ago were now hidden away in
darkness it was so bleak in there that
they couldn't see the cup of ramen
steaming inches away from their faces in
moments like this the usual advice is to
stay calm and wait for the situation to
be resolved after all if you tried to
take anything into your own hands you
might fall over and injure yourself
normally this is good advice it's less
effective when the thing that wishes you
grave injury is actively on its way and
sitting in the dark certainly isn't
going to stop it elsewhere in the
building the engineering team were
scrambling like there was no tomorrow to
rectify their mistake partially because
if scp-173 got to them before they'd
gotten the lights working again there
really would be no tomorrow with their
mini flashlights they desperately search
for any way to rectify the issue and get
everything turned back on in a normal
company the biggest concern in a
situation like this might be massive
irretrievable data loss but of course at
the scp foundation the issue is more a
massive and irretrievable loss of human
life and also the data too a few miles
south of site 19 a different kind of
cavalry were on its way a detachment of
mtf new 7 hammer down were on their way
in a pair of armored helicopters their
assault rifles had flashlights fixed to
them and their helmets came fitted with
night vision goggles as standard their
intel suggested a large portion of site
19 sector c had gone dark for whatever
reason and they were ready to drop in
and get things back under control the
one question was whether they'd get
there in time to save the people in the
break room as the sculpture drew ever
closer to their location
speaking of the group of research and
administration staff were still just
sitting around waiting for the lights to
turn back on one of the more senior
researchers in the room dr sherry bruiss
was a lifelong smoker and as such she
was fishing around in her purse for her
zippo lighter to shed some light on the
situation her rummaging was so loud that
she could barely even hear the door to
the room beginning to creak open but she
heard the first snap and the awful
animalistic chorus of screams that
followed crunch crunch crunch as each of
her fellow members of foundation
personnel fell she could feel the thing
killing them getting closer she could
almost feel the same icy limbs gripping
her skull when she whipped out and lit
the zippo the flame coming alive in
front of her face with a pleasing
metallic click it didn't offer much
light just enough for her to see the
monster looming inches away from her
face scp-173
limbs outstretched and ready the rest of
the room was silent she knew in that
moment she was the only one alive in
here now but she still wasn't the only
survivor yet that all depended on what
happened next the flame danced and the
sculpture remained frozen in place
standing so close to her it wanted her
it wanted to hear her neck crunch the
flames began to dance erratically and dr
brewess felt her heart rate spike one
careless breath
and the light keeping her alive would be
gone but even if she did everything
right here it might not be enough to
save her it didn't even need a second to
do what it wanted so badly to do the
light seemed almost to flicker getting
smaller getting weaker dr brewess felt
tears dribbling down her cheeks any
second now click the lights above her
turned back on she could have screamed
in delirious relief but that might have
also been a scream at the expense of her
many dead co-workers littered around the
room either way her thoughts were
interrupted by a staccato burst of
footsteps followed by the boom of the
door being kicked in by a booted foot
the members of hammerdown were standing
in the doorway she was saved in the
hours that followed things were righted
as best as they could be with so many
deaths the sculpture was returned to
containment the bodies were cleared away
the electrical issues were fixed much
would continue on as normal after that
day death after all was an occupational
hazard for those working at the scp
foundation but one thing forever changed
scp-173
was never underestimated again now go
check out scp-173 origin story how
scp-173 got to site 19 and the ipods
scp-131 for more terrifying incidents
involving this singularly savage statue